ganz schnell zum nächsten
Tagesordnungspunkt da steht schon die
Ministerin Nancy fazer es geht um das
neue Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
Frau Präsident Herren die
Bundesregierung
hat weniger als einen Neustart in der
Migrationspolitik vorgenommen denn
Deutschland ist ein vielfältiges
Einwanderungsland und wir brauchen
endlich eine Politik die diesem Anspruch
auch gerecht wird
zu lange meine Damen und Herren wurde
Einwanderungen nach Deutschland nicht
aktiv gestaltet sondern wiederwillig
verwaltet man hat immer neue
bürokratische Hürden geschaffen die
viele gerade gut integrierte Menschen
verunsichert und frustriert haben damit
ist es jetzt Gott sei Dank vorbei denn
diese Koalition schafft ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht meine Damen und
Herren
[Applaus]
das ist eine große und komplexe Aufgabe
die wir in mehreren Schritten angehen
und den ersten Schritt machen wir heute
mit dem Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht wir
wollen dass Menschen die gut integriert
sind auch gute Chancen in Deutschland
haben deshalb geben wir Menschen die
seit mindestens fünf Jahren geduldet in
Deutschland leben für ein Jahr das
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht diese Zeit
können sie nutzen um die übrigen
Voraussetzungen für ein Bleiberecht zu
erfüllen dazu gehört vor allem dass sie
ihren Lebensunterhalt selbst bestreiten
dass sie Deutsch sprechen und dass sie
ihre Identität eindeutig nachweisen
können wenn alle Voraussetzungen erfüllt
sind erhalten diese Menschen ein
dauerhaftes Bleiberecht in Deutschland
wir geben Ihnen damit die Chance auch
die Zuversicht dauerhaft dazu zu gehören
das Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht ist das
Ende der kettendung und damit auch das
Ende der Bürokratie und der Unsicherheit
vor allen Dingen die damit für die
Menschen verbunden war für die
betroffenen Menschen war das eine große
Belastung aber auch für die Behörden
waren kettendungen schwierig und
übrigens auch für viele mittelständische
Unternehmen die gut integrierten
Menschen gerne ein Perspektive in
unserem Land geben wollen es ist
allerhöchste Zeit das zu ändern
ergänzend zum Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht
bringen wir heute weitere Veränderungen
auf den Weg wir ermöglichen gut
integrierten jungen Menschen unter 27
Jahren schon nach drei Jahren ein
Bleiberecht wir erleichtern es den
Fachkräften die wir so dringend brauchen
ihre Familien mit nach Deutschland zu
bringen
Familienangehörige müssen künftig nicht
mehr nachweisen dass sie Deutsch
sprechen müssen das war übrigens in
allen anderen europäischen Ländern schon
länger der Fall und das ist mir sehr
wichtig wir sorgen für Integration von
Anfang an
AsylbewerberInnen Asylbewerber können
künftig schon während des laufenden
Asylverfahrens Sprach- und
Integrationskurse machen unabhängig von
einer bleiberechtsperspektive und das
ist auch gut so meine Damen und Herren
[Applaus]
unsere Grundhaltung ist klar wer gut
integriert ist soll in Deutschland gute
Chancen haben umgekehrt gilt aber auch
wer sich nicht an die Regeln hält
bekommt diese Chance nicht das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht gilt nicht für
Straftäter und es gilt nicht für
Personen die falsche Angaben über ihre
Identität machen im Gegenteil
Straftätern kann künftig leichter das
Aufenthaltsrecht entzogen werden wir
erleichtern auch die Anordnung von
Abschiebehaft damit sie vor ihrer
Abschiebung nicht untertauchen können
insofern ist das glaube ich auch gut so
meine Damen und Herren
die Grundlage für ein modernes
Einwanderungsland ist Klarheit klare
Chancen und genauso klare Regeln auf dem
Weg dahin machen wir mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht einen großen ersten
Schritt in die richtige Richtung und ich
darf mich bei allen bedanken die an
diesem Gesetz mitgearbeitet haben vielen
Dank
die Bundesinnenminister nennt sie Feser
war das ja die
ampelkoalitionspartner SPD Grüne und FDP
setzen ein zentrales
flüchtlingspolitisches Vorhaben aus
ihrem Koalitionsvertrag um mit diesem
sogenannten Chancen und Aufenthaltsrecht
wollen Sie also gut integrierten
Ausländern unter die Arme greifen die
schon mehrere Jahre ohne gesicherten
Status in Deutschland leben
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine Damen und
Herren wir beraten heute das erste
migrationspaket der Ampel zwei weitere
sollen folgen und die Ampel bezeichnet
das Gesetz selbst als Paradigmenwechsel
und meine Damen und Herren in der Tat es
handelt sich um einen Bruch mit einer
rechtsradition nämlich der
Unterscheidung einerseits zwischen dem
Asylrecht und andererseits der
allgemeinen migration
in christlicher Verantwortung und
humanitär ist es wichtig dass wir
verfolgten Menschen helfen und
Deutschland hat sein großes Herz in den
letzten Jahren unter Beweis gestellt und
tut das auch aktuell mit der Hilfe und
Unterbringung von rund eine Million
Menschen aus der Ukraine
es muss aber unser Anspruch sein und das
ist wichtig dass das Asylsystem nicht
missbraucht wird wenn nicht unsere
Gesellschaft und letztlich damit unser
Staat entscheidet wer zu uns kommt
sondern das in die Beliebigkeit eines
einzelnen gestellt wird dann geben wir
letztlich unsere Staatlichkeit auf und
damit auch die Ordnung und Steuerung die
Aufnahmefähigkeit unseres Landes müssen
wir den Menschen bereithalten die
tatsächlich verfolgt sind
die gesamtschutzquote
lag in den vergangenen Jahren bei
durchschnittlich 40 Prozent
der SPD-Kollege Hakan demia hat in einer
Debatte zutreffend gesagt dass da auch
formale Entscheidungen noch dazu kommt
und auch Entscheidungen durch
gerichtsklageverfahren sind
hinzuzuziehen sie kommen auf 70%
und nehmen wir mal diesen 70 Prozent an
kommen wir zu den Zahlen zwischen 2015
und heute sind rund 2 Millionen Menschen
zu uns gekommen und haben erstmalig ein
Asylantrag gestellt wir können rechnen
30 Prozent zwei Millionen Menschen das
heißt wir haben 600.000 Menschen die
unser System genutzt haben die die
Leistungen voll beansprucht haben und
das können wir uns wirklich nicht mehr
länger leisten meine Damen und Herren
das A und O ist ein funktionsfähiges
europäisches Asylsystem und ich rufe
Ihnen das heute auch noch mal zu von der
SPD und grün setzen Sie sich in Brüssel
dafür ein dass das grenzverfahren
welches die Kommission vorsieht mit
einer Vorprüfung kommt das ist das
einzige und wirksamste Mittel gegen ein
Missbrauch ganz wichtig
aber noch viel wichtiger ist natürlich
dass wir in Deutschland keine
Fehlanreize setzen und genau dies tut
der aktuelle Gesetzentwurf der die
Bezeichnung Ampel Amnestiegesetz
verdient hat belohnt werden gerade
diejenigen Ausländer die bislang nicht
abgeschoben werden konnten weil sie
entweder bei der Klärung der Identität
nicht mitgewirkt haben oder sogar aktiv
getäuscht haben und jetzt ist auch noch
das erklärte Ziel der Ampel den
Asylbewerbern aus Herkunftsstaaten die
regelmäßig gar keinen Anspruch haben
auch noch frühzeitig
Integrationsleistungen frühzeitig
Sprachkenntnis zukommen zu lassen und
sie haben es nicht verstanden spätestens
hier durch wird das deutliche Signal
gesetzt jeder kann kommen wer es
geschafft hat nach Deutschland zu kommen
auch bleiben und genau und deshalb lehnt
die
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion das
vorliegende Gesetz ab vielen Dank
sagt Detlef sei für die CDU CSU-Fraktion
und hat hier die Kritik formuliert erste
Beratung allerdings erst dieses
Gesetzentwurfes abgestimmt wird heute
noch nicht wir hören jetzt für die
Grünen die nächste Rednerin
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Ministerin sehr
geehrte Kolleginnen und Kollegen meine
Damen und Herren
ich habe eine gute Nachricht wir sind im
Hier und Jetzt angekommen mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsgesetz gehen wir das
erste in einer Reihe von modernen
einwanderungsregelungen an und machen
Schluss mit einer Politik der Angst die
zurückliegenden Legislaturperioden waren
vor allem geprägt von Verschärfungen des
asyl- und Aufenthaltsrechts wir wenden
uns dem Thema dagegen mit einer
positiven Grundhaltung zu und gehen so
nichts weniger als eine
Paradigmenwechsel an
wir schauen auf die Chancen wir schauen
auf die Chance von Migration nicht mehr
nur auf die Probleme wir stellen die
Weichen für eine Integrationspolitik der
Zukunft eine die um die Herausforderung
weiß die an Einwanderungsland mit sich
bringt und wir machen das gut und gerne
auch wenn es nicht leicht ist sobald das
Wort Migration fällt gibt es gibt es
Fragen
Ängste Sorgen dabei ist Migration eine
historische Normalität seit
Menschengedenken sie ist nichts
Außergewöhnliches die wir eine
Katastrophe über uns kommt nicht die
Migration ist häufig das Problem sondern
der Umgang damit meine Damen und Herren
schauen wir aber ins Land
wissen wir die Gesellschaft die Menschen
sind schon oft weiter viel weiter jede
vierte Person in diesem Land hat eine
internationale familienbiografie das
Thema wird stets benutzt für Populismus
es steckt voll von Angstmacherei Mythen
Halbwahrheiten und Lügen fragen Sie Herr
März wenn sie von der Union nun statt
vom sozialtourismus über sogenannte
pulfaktoren sprechen dann sollten wir
noch einmal klarstellen das Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz ich spreche sie gar
nicht an was auch egal das Chancen
Aufenthaltsgesetz lockt sicherlich
niemanden mehr hinterm Ofen hervor
nämlich erstmal fünf Jahre in der
Duldung zu leben möglicherweise die
Familie nicht hier zu haben und danach
ein Jahr lang Probe auf Probe Teil
dieser Gesellschaft zu sein es geht also
darum Menschen die bereits hier sind
diese Chance zu geben
die süßmut-kommission hat im übrigen in
ihrem Bericht im Jahre 2001 die
Abschaffung der kettenblutung gefordert
das ist jetzt
aber her und nun machen wir endlich
einen großen Schritt in die richtige
Richtung
[Applaus]
ich komme aus Duisburg und wir sind
Industriestadt spreche ich vor Ort mit
Vertretern Vertretern der Stahlbranche
oder der IHK kommen zahlreiche Beispiele
von gut ausgebildeten Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeitern die plötzlich in der
Abschiebung landen nachdem sie und ihre
Unternehmen sich um Arbeitsplatz
Arbeitsplatz Wohnung oder
Kinderbetreuung gekümmert haben das hier
das können wir uns nicht mehr leisten
weder moralisch noch wirtschaftlich
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren mit dem
Chancen Aufenthaltsrecht erhalten
geduldete Personen die seit fünf Jahren
straffrei in Deutschland leben endlich
eine menschenrechtskonforme Perspektive
das betrifft über 240.000 Menschen deren
Asylanträge abgelehnt wurden die aber
auch nicht in ihrer Heimat zurück in
ihre Heimat zurückkehren können weil
dort beispielsweise Krieg herrscht die
Taliban oder Diktatoren herrschen und
regieren das bedeutet sie sind in der
Regel für wenige Monate vor einer
Abschiebung geschützt danach wird erneut
geprüft diese entwürdigende Praxis
werden wir gemeinsam in der Ampel
endlich beenden
mit diesem Aufenthaltsrecht auf Probe
haben die Betroffenen die Chance die
Voraussetzung für eine
Aufenthaltserlaubnis auf Dauer zu
erbringen das ist ein lang ersehnter
Meilenstein in der Asylpolitik denn
damit ermöglichen wir einen Spurwechsel
Menschen die seit Jahren in Deutschland
leben aber bisher kann Asyl erhalten
haben bekommen eine Chance ganz nebenbei
gewinnen wir somit auch 10.000
motivierte Arbeitskräfte die unser Land
so dringend benötigt mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht leisten wir also einen
Beitrag ja Sie können so lange
reinschreiben wie Sie wollen es nützt
ihn nur nichts mit dem Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht leisten wir also einen
Beitrag gegen den Arbeitskräftemangel
gerade Handwerksbetriebe gerade
Handwerksbetriebe und mittelständische
Unternehmen werden von der Neuregelung
profitieren viele Arbeitgeberinnen und
Arbeitgeber müssen sich nicht mehr
fragen ob Ihre Mitarbeiterinnen
Mitarbeiter mit Duldung womöglich von
heute auf morgen abgeschoben werden
müssen und 130.000 Menschen die länger
als fünf Jahre hier leben und geduldet
sind können direkt von dieser Regelung
profitieren viele geduldete die
jahrelangen Angst vor einer Abschiebung
leben mussten erhalten endlich die
Chance auf ein dauerhaftes Bleiberecht
und zu pragmatischen Verfahren im
Aufenthaltsrecht gehört dann eben auch
das Prinzip Ausbildung statt Abschiebung
eine Win-Win-Situation für alle
Beteiligten
am Ende noch ein Wort zu all jenen jetzt
sind sie mal dran am Ende ein Wort noch
zu all jene die Migration für rechten
Populismus besprochen also fühlen Sie
sich ruhig angesprochen als weiteren
großen Schritt braucht es ein gut
funktionierendes Einwanderungsgesetz wie
ist die Ampelkoalition ebenso anstoßen
wird und deshalb werden wir unter
anderem das staatsangehörigkeits sowie
das Familien als auch das
Einwanderungsrecht reformieren wir
wollen auch das asyl-prozessrecht
reformieren und damit auch die
unabhängige asylverfahrensberatung
einführen wir verstehen Vielfalt als
Chance und gleichzeitig als Ressource
auf dem Arbeitsmarkt
und ja wir wissen um die krisenhafte
Zeiten der wir uns gerade befinden aber
die Bewältigung dieser Zeit auf Kosten
von Humanität ist für uns inakzeptabel
und menschenverachtend
ich freue mich also dass wir in der
Gegenwart angekommen sind und uns
endlich zu unserem Einwanderungsland
bekennen einfach weil wir eines sind
vielen Dank
wer am 1 Januar 2022 fünf Jahre in
Deutschland gelebt hat und nicht
straffällig geworden ist soll nach dem
Vorstellung der Ampelkoalition ein
Aufenthaltsrecht erhalten hat dann ein
Jahr Zeit die Voraussetzung für eine
reguläres Bleiberecht zu erfüllen
sehr geehrte Präsidentin meine Damen und
Herren das neue Gesetz dass die
Bedingungen für eine
Aufenthaltserlaubnis aufweicht hat den
Zweck abgelehnter Asylbewerber die
trotzdem unter einer Reihe bekannter
Vorwände nicht abgeschoben werden
geduldet werden nun nach fünf Jahren
endgültig Deutschland aufzubürden dieser
sogenannte chancenaufenthalt soll
Deutschland endgültig die Chance nehmen
Asylbetrüger irgendwann auch mal wieder
loszuwerden was sind die Bausteine
dieser Ruchlosigkeit bei der Aufrechnung
dieser Mindestaufenthaltsdauer waren
bislang Zeiten nicht enthalten in denen
der nur geduldete Migrant der also
keinen asylgrundnachweis seine Identität
gegebenenfalls verschleiert womit er das
eigentlich angezeigte abschiebezielland
verheimlicht diese Zeiten der bewussten
Verschleierung der eigen Qualität werden
künftig als warteleistung auf der Uhr
bis zur dauerhaften Aufenthaltserlaubnis
angerechnet überhaupt soll künftig
ungeklärte Identität
Hindernis mehr sein wahrlich ein
Fortschritt nur nicht für Deutschland
nur nicht für Freunde der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit meine Damen und
Herren
im gleichen Sinne werden noch weitere
Hürden für die Aufenthaltserlaubnis
geschleift hat man sich einfach einer
geplanten Abschiebung durch zeitweises
Untertauchen entzogen so war das früher
ein No-Go ab sofort aber kein Problem
mehr Rechtsbrecher werden von dieser
Regierung belohnt das ist nur konsequent
wo es darum geht abgelehnte Asylbewerber
also Leute ohne Asylgrund hierzulande
trotz allem zu verstetigen da ist
Fluchtpunkt aller Regelungen natürlich
der Erfolg der Täuschung der Lohn der
Lüge meine Damen und Herren warum etwa
sollen Asylbewerber bis 27 schon nach
drei Jahren hier in den permanenten
Aufenthalt übergehen ganz einfach Asyl
und Klageverfahren dauern typischerweise
gerade etwas länger so wird hier just
bevor ein Gericht über das tatsächliche
bestehen oder nicht Bestehen des
schutzanspruchs geurteilt hat noch eilig
ein Aufenthaltsrecht gezimmert das
Urteil des Rechtsstaats könnte da
womöglich stören
Integrationskurse sollen bislang
natürlich nicht finanziert werden für
Fälle absehbarer nicht Anerkennung etwa
für Bewerber aus sicheren
Herkunftsländern auch hier sollen nun
integrationstatbestände auf dem Papier
ermöglicht werden offensichtlich
einziger Zweck nachfolgend dann die
eigentlich kontraindizierte Anerkennung
doch noch irgendwie durchzudrücken
während die Deutschen sich das Heizen
nicht mehr leisten können wird ihr
Steuergeld für illegale verheizt
und der von der Regierung zur
Legitimierung von Unrecht immer gerne
beigebrachte
argumentationspast partout eines
Fachkräftemangels ist bei
millionenfacher europäischer
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit und einer
viertelmillionen arbeitslosen
anerkannten Asylbewerbern plus 400.000
Erwerbs für eu-krainer natürlich ein
Witz allerdings ein schlechter ja
eigentlich eine Verhöhnung aller dieser
normalen Arbeitslosen denen hier
ausgerechnet importierte Asylbetrüger
gegebenenfalls vorgezogen würden Chancen
Aufenthalt die Regierung nimmt hier
allein die Sicht abgelehnte Ausländer
ein die eine Chance haben sich in
Deutschland gut gehen zu lassen die
Prioritäten sind klar deutsche
Interessen sind es nicht
übrigens wollen Sie denn Menschen in ein
Land locken wo Energie und Wohnraum
knapp ist nicht vorhanden sind wo nicht
mehr geheizt und nur noch kalt geduscht
werden darf wenn es nach den Grünen geht
ähnelt das nicht den Menschen und
würdigen Bedingungen deren Gerichte
Abschiebungen etwa nach Griechenland
verbieten die Stellungnahme des
landkreistags bestätigt dass der
betroffene Personenkreis kein Interesse
an der Füllung der gesetzlichen
Mitwirkungspflicht habe oder sich jemals
ernsthaft integrieren wolle verweilt und
in Deutschland sei ausschließlich
wirtschaftliche vorteilsname aber statt
auf feministische Außenpolitik setzt
Frau Feser eher auf antifeministische
Innenpolitik und will Zuwanderergruppen
unbedingt im Land belassen die
überproportional oft Gewalt und
Sexualdelikte verüben man fragt sich
langsam produziert die Ampel in der
Energiefrage womöglich absichtlich so
viel mords und davon abzulenken was für
verheerende Pläne sie in der
Migrationspolitik haben
diese Chancen gehen alle nur zu Lasten
Deutschlands meine Damen und Herren und
deshalb muss es dabei bleiben keine
Laufzeitverlängerung für illegale ich
danke Ihnen
für die FDP-Fraktion hat nun der Kollege
Stefan
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen nach so viel
schrillen Tönen will ich doch noch mal
versuchen herauszustellen
herauszuarbeiten worin die Chancen
bestehen und worin der paladinwechsel
eigentlich besteht die die Koalition
planen wir wollen in Zukunft mehr
reguläre Immigration und weniger
irreguläre Migration bei uns haben eine
Zukunft wollen wir eine klare Trennung
haben wer benötigt Schutz und Hilfe von
uns der soll sie auch bei uns finden
wer sucht eigentlich Arbeit oder
Ausbildung bei uns dem wollen wir ein
besseres Angebot unterbreiten denn der
Bedarf an Arbeitskräften bei uns ist
groß
aber auf wen trifft wieder das eine noch
das andere zu dann müssen wir auch
konsequent auf der Ausreise bestehenden
nötigenfalls auch konsequenter als
bislang durchsetzen das ist der
Paradigmenwechsel
das Problem ist dass in der
Vergangenheit diese klare Trennung und
diese konsequente Umsetzung eben nicht
stattgefunden hat und deswegen leben
zurzeit
136.000 Menschen in diesem Land seit
mehr als fünf Jahren in einem
duldungsstatus bei uns hängen im
Sozialsystem fest verlieren auch selbst
und vor ihren Kindern an Selbstachtung
gewinnen nie die Akzeptanz und die
Anerkennung der Menschen in diesem Land
sie sind mit einem Wort nie so richtig
angekommen und gleichwohl reisen sie
seit Jahren auch nicht aus und auch
ihnen ist es nie gelungen die Ausreise
durchzusetzen
das sind Menschen deren Kinder besser
Deutsch sprechen als die Sprache ihre
Eltern und Großeltern den eigentlich
viel
Integrationspotenzial steckt und diese
Potenziale zu heben das muss doch unsere
Aufgabe sein wir wollen dass diese
Menschen
dann eben auf eigenen Beinen stehen dass
sie ihr Leben auch bei uns selber in die
Hand nehmen mit einem Wort meine Damen
und Herren wir wollen aus
Hilfeempfängern
Steuerzahler machen in diesem Land
in Vergangenheit kosten sie uns Geld wir
wollen dass Sie einen Beitrag leisten
können zum Gelingen unserer Gesellschaft
das ja auch würde wiederfinden können
aber natürlich bekommt man nichts auf
der Welt einfach so geschenkt das hat
Voraussetzungen man muss sich straffrei
bei uns im Land Verhalten die Identität
muss geklärt sein muss wirtschaftlich
auf eigenen beiden stehen können und wem
das eben nicht gelingt der fällt nach
einem Jahr wieder in den duldungsstatus
zurück und muss dann ebenfalls ausreißen
in Zukunft wollen wir eben nicht mehr
und das ist der andere Teil für uns
notwendiger zugehört wir wollen das in
Zukunft nicht mehr Hunderttausende von
Menschen jahrelang geduldet sind und
deswegen gehört zum chancenaufenthalt
auch noch eine zweite Komponente hinzu
die auch noch kommen wird und die
Vorbereitung ist beim Innenministerium
nämlich die Verfahrensbeschleunigung das
ist ein Teil ein integraler Teil unseres
Paketes wir wollen das Gefühl eben nicht
mehr jahrelang Menschen in diesen
Bildungsstatus verharren und deswegen
muss auch Ausreise unnötigen was
Abschiebung konsequent umgesetzt werden
deswegen ist im Paket auch enthalten
dass sie abschiebe Haft verlängert wird
um die Abschiebungen besser möglich zu
machen das ist unsere Kombination aus
Humanität die wir ernst nehmen und
wollen aber auch Kontrolle die auch dazu
gehört meine Damen und Herren
und ich finde es deswegen Herr Kollege
seiff auch unzutreffend wenn sie sagen
wir setzen Fehlanreize weil ihr auch in
klaren Stichtag setzen der
chancenaufenthalt der heute eingebracht
wird wirkt nämlich nur in die
Vergangenheit es wird ein Stichtag
versehen nämlich mit dem ersten Januar
2022 vor dem zurückwirkend auf fünf
Jahre jemand im Land sein muss er wird
also nicht in die Zukunft und Anreize
können doch nur eine Zukunft wirken und
deswegen finde Diagnose unzutreffend
Herr Kollege Seif und
weil auch das Gehalt noch gesagt worden
ist es kommen ja doch dadurch auch nicht
mehr Menschen ins Land wir sprechen von
Menschen die schon da sind die seit
Jahren hier bei uns im System hängen und
das sind deswegen auch nicht die
Menschen die Turnhallen auffüllen
sondern wir meinen die Menschen die hier
sind und die wir doch eigentlich
brauchen Menschen die hier einen Beitrag
leisten davon profitieren die
Verbraucher wir erleben doch Tag für Tag
dass Menschen im Dienstleistungsberufen
fehlen im Verkauf einen Flughäfen im
Handwerk davon profitieren die
Arbeitgeber weil es sie nicht mehr
gelingt Arbeitskräfte zu finden
Ausbildungsplätze zu besetzen dann
profitieren natürlich die geduldigten
selber und vor allem auch der Staat denn
jetzt kosten diese Menschen und künftig
sollen Sie etwas beitragen und deswegen
gibt es viele viele Gründe das was wir
heute einbringen auch zu beschließen
voranzubringen und deswegen ist ein
gutes Gesetz für das ich mich beim BMI
auch herzlich bedanke
sagt Stefan Tomé für die FDP-Fraktion ja
die Stichtagsregelung also erster Januar
2022 das war auch der FDP wichtig das
soll also so deswegen wird das
Aufenthaltsrecht lediglich sogenannte
Altfälle betreffen allerdings gibt es an
dieser Stichtagsregelung auch durchaus
innerhalb der Ampelkoalition Kritik
jetzt werden wir für die Linke Klara
Bünger
als ich Migration in ihrem
Koalitionsvertrag gelesen habe war ich
erstmal positiv überrascht nach einem
Jahr muss ich aber feststellen von dem
groß angekündigten Neustart in der
Migrationspolitik so wie sie es auch
gesagt haben Frau Ministerin kann keine
Rede sein diese Kritik kommt nicht nur
von mir auch viele
zivilgesellschaftliche Organisation sind
enttäuscht der viel zu unambitionierte
Gesetzentwurf für ein Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht zeigt deutlich wo die
Probleme liegen laut Koalitionsvertrag
wollen sie eigentlich Menschen aus der
Kettenbildung rausholen mit dem jetzigen
Vorschlag bekommen aber wie die
Bundesregierung selber schätzt nur etwa
34.000 Menschen ein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht das sind nicht besonders
viele gegenüber den mehr als 240.000
Personen die nur eine Duldung haben und
die eigentlich einen Aufenthaltstitel
bräuchten
sollen diese Menschen etwa keine Chance
erhalten die Anforderung für das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht und außerdem viel zu
hoch zum Beispiel wird erwartet dass
Betroffene nach einem Jahr ihren
Lebensunterhalt sichern und das nachdem
sie über Jahre hinweg systematisch
ausgegrenzt und vom Arbeitsmarkt
ferngehalten wurden
hier bräuchte es
Verlängerungsmöglichkeiten das gleiche
gilt auch beim Spracherwerb
enttäuschend ist außerdem dass sie den
Gesetz dass sie in dem Gesetzentwurf
nicht nutzen um die identitätsklärung
per eidesstattlicher Versicherung
einzuführen das verstehe ich wirklich
nicht weil es in ihrem Koalitionsvertrag
so drinsteht und wenn Sie es wirklich
ernst meinen würden müsste das Gesetz
stichtagsunabhängig gelten nur so würde
wirklich allen langjährig geduldeten
Menschen der Übergang in ein dauerhaftes
Bleiberecht eröffnet
und ich werde das Gefühl nicht los dass
sie sich von Friedrich Merz und Co
treiben lassen kurz nachdem er von
sozialtourismus gesprochen hatte legte
Innenministerin faesar nach und sprach
sich für eine weitere Abschottung der
Grenzen aus
illegale Migration müsse gestoppt werden
so sieht doch kein Paradigmenwechsel in
der Migrationspolitik aus die Worte der
Innenministerin klingt für mich eher wie
eine Fortsetzung der Politik von
Seehofer
und dabei ist vieles was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht richtig zum
Beispiel die Erleichterung beim
Familiennachzug aber die müssen sie auch
endlich umsetzen
zig Verschärfung ich glaube es waren 15
die in den letzten Jahren durchgezogen
wurden sind nach wie vor in Kraft das
darf so nicht bleiben deshalb fordern
wir auch in unserem Antrag dass in einem
ersten Schritt die seit 2015
vorgenommenen Verschärfung im
abschiebungsverfahren zurückgenommen
werden müssen das betrifft insbesondere
überraschungsabschiebungen ohne
Vorankündigung und den Umgang mit
psychisch und physisch kranken Menschen
vielen Dank
klar Dünger war das für die
Linksfraktion jetzt hören wir für die
Sozialdemokraten deren
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
der Krise
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen bei dem heute
eingebrachten Gesetz zum Chancen
Aufenthalt handelt es sich nicht um
einen Paradigmenwechsel sondern es
handelt sich um die Anerkennung von
Lebensrealitäten bei uns im Land die
leider von unserem letzten
Koalitionspartner viel zu lange
verleugnet worden sind und darum ist es
ein guter Tag für viele Menschen bei uns
im Land die bereits lange hier sind die
Teil unserer Mitte sind die in unserer
Mitte in Dörfern in Stadtteilen gut
integriert sind und diese Menschen
wollen wir aus dieser Unsicherheit der
kettendungen herausholen Ihnen eine
klare Perspektive geben und in eine
klare Perspektive gegen dass Sie zu uns
in diesem Land dazu hören und das ist
gut dass wir das heute gemeinsam auf den
Weg gehen
und ich will das ausdrücklich sagen und
ich bin dem Bundesinnenministerium der
Bundesministerin nennt sich Fehse aber
auch den
Koalitionsfraktionen von grünen FDP aber
natürlich auch bei uns in der
Sozialdemokratie dankbar dass wir das
gemeinsam auf den Weg gebracht hat weil
es wirklich gut integrierten Menschen
bei uns im Land eine klare Perspektive
gibt und ich will das deutlich sagen es
sind doch die Beispiele die wir alle bei
uns aus den Wahlkreisen kennen es sind
die Meldungen die wir plötzlich in der
Tagespresse erleben dass jemand
abgeschoben werden soll der lange im
Handwerksunternehmen nebenan gearbeitet
hat der im Wirtschaftsbetrieb gearbeitet
hat und plötzlich aus der Mitte seiner
belegschaftskollegen herausgerissen wird
es sind die Kinder die letztendlich
plötzlich morgens aus der Schule
herausgenommen werden weil sie in
Kettenduldung in dieser Unsicherheit
gelebt werden und diesen Menschen die
hier sind diese Perspektive zu geben es
ist richtig und ich will es mal deutlich
sagen genau diese Fälle sind es doch
letztendlich wo auch Kolleginnen und
Kollegen aus der Unionsfraktion dann
Briefe schreiben sich beschweren das ist
doch nicht sein kann und heute
verleugnen sie diese Lebensrealitäten da
kann ich ganz ehrlich gesagt nur über
den Kopf schütten
und ich will das auch noch mal
unterstreichen es geht um diejenigen die
länger als fünf Jahre hier gewesen sind
die nicht straffällig geworden sind
denen wir jetzt genau diese Chance
einräumen dazu beizutragen dass sie den
Lebensunterhalt sichern aufklären auch
über die Entität wo es noch Unklarheiten
letztendlich gibt und die dann die klare
Chance und Perspektive geben weiterhin
Teil unserer Mitte letztendlich auch zu
sein und das werden wir jetzt auch im
parlamentarischen Verfahren auch
gemeinsam voranbringen aber es ist
völlig richtig es ist nur ein Teil der
Vorhaben die wir letztendlich auch in
der Ampelkoalition voranbringen wollen
es geht auch um die Beschleunigung der
Asylverfahren es geht auch um die
Modernisierung des
Staatsangehörigkeitsrechts und es geht
um ein modernes Einwanderungsrecht für
dieses Land was wir dringend brauchen
und dass wir eigentlich schon längst
hätten haben müssen und das wollen wir
jetzt Ampelkoalition auch gemeinsam
voranbringen
und ich sag's auch ganz deutlich zum
Abschluss genauso gut ist es richtig den
Zugang zu Integrationskursen bereits von
Beginn an zu öffnen um Grundwerte
unserer Verfassung zu vermitteln
Grundwerte zu vermitteln über Recht und
Kultur und ich kann Ihnen nur eins sagen
Herr kurio nutzen Sie so ein
Integrationskurs auch mal für sich als
Chance es kann doch mal Grundlagen
unserer Verfassung vermitteln und es
kann hier engstirniges zwölfjähriges
Geschichtsverständnis vielleicht auch
noch mal überholen in diesem Sinne ein
gutes Gesetz was wir voranbringen
sie sagt dirkwiese hier für die
SPD-Fraktion
[Musik]
[Applaus]
für innen und Heimat der
cdu/csu-fraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin werte
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die Ampel
schafft ein Amnestiegesetz für Menschen
die ausreisepflichtig sind die hier
keinen Schutzanspruch haben keinen
schutzbedürfen sondern rechtskräftig
ausreisepflichtig sind und das hat auch
nichts mit Humanität zu tun weil denen
die Schutz brauchen den geben wir hier
diesen Schutz auch und liebe Kolleginnen
Kollegen der Ampel sie führen die
Menschen schlichtweg in die Irre mit
ihrem sogenannten chancenaufenthalt
nützen sie nur einer Personengruppe
unter den geduldeten nämlich denen ohne
geklärte Identität alle anderen
geduldeten haben heute schon die
Möglichkeit zu arbeiten und spätestens
nach sechs bis acht Jahren ihren
Daueraufenthalt zu bekommen nur die ohne
geklärte Identität die ihren Kollegen
von denen wir nicht wissen woher sie
kommen und wie sie heißen denen
ermöglichen sie die das Bleiberecht und
dann kommt im zweiten migrationspaket
Frau Ministerin mit Sicherheit die
eidesstattliche Erklärung wo dann genau
diese Personengruppe sagen kann ich
heiße so und so ich komme da und daher
und dann müssen wir das glauben das ist
ein großes Sicherheitsrisiko und sie
führen die Menschen hier in die Irre
Herr Kollege Thome
und natürlich Stichtag wirkt rückwirkend
ja für die Zukunft brauchen sie das gar
nicht mehr weil sie schaffen ja weitere
bleiberechte für Erwachsene aber
insbesondere für sogenannte Jugendliche
und jugendlich ist man nach der Ampel im
aufenthaltsrechtlichen sind zukünftig
bis zum zarten Alter von 27 Jahren bis
27 Jahren kann das Privileg genutzt
werden als sogenannter Jugendlicher hier
ein Bleiberecht zu erhalten das ist
wirklich keine geordnete
Migrationspolitik liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen und wenn man weiß dass 2021 73
Prozent aller Asylanträge von Menschen
bis 29 so ist die Statistik halt
gestellt wurden dann wissen Sie was dies
für eine Öffnung hier in Deutschland
bedeutet für die Zukunft liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
sie wollen dass es zukünftig heißt jeder
der irgendwie nach Deutschland kommt
kann auch hier bleiben egal ob er
Schutzanspruch hat oder nicht und Herr
Kollege Thomas
eine Frage oder Bemerkung aber immer
vielen Dank Frau Präsidentin und schöne
Sache Herr Kollege dass sie die Frage
zulassen wir ermöglichen mit dem Chancen
taufenthaltsrechts 130.000 Menschen in
diesem Land eine echte Perspektive die
hier eine Perspektive suchen und wir
beide wir kommen aus dem gleichen
wirtschaftsstarken Bundesland
Baden-Württemberg und stellen da an
allen Orten fest dass wir einen heftigen
Personalmangel haben egal ob es am
Handwerker ist beim Friseur oder in der
Gießerei oder in der Härterei überall
gibt es
Fachkräftemangel Arbeitskräftemangel und
meine Frage an Sie wäre wenn ich bei mir
mit Betrieben spreche dann höre ich
immer wieder dass sie das Chancen
Aufenthaltsrecht gut finden auch die IHK
hat ausdrücklich gesagt dass das eine
gute Sache ist und in meinem Wahlkreis
gibt es immer wieder Betriebe die es
auch gut finden dass damit wirklich
Menschen die nur geduldet sind die eine
Werkbank stehen damit bleiben können und
dauerhaft ihren Arbeitsplatz behalten
und damit auch den Wirtschaftsstandort
Deutschland oder bei uns
Baden-Württemberg unterstützen meine
Frage an Sie sie in ihrem Wahlkreis auch
solche Betriebe Kollege ich habe die
Diskussionen auch aber bei mir im
Wahlkreis werden Fachkräfte gesucht das
ist nicht die Personengruppe und die es
heute in ihrem Gesetz geht sie schaffen
damit sie schaffen damit
sie schaffen damit Anreize für un- und
minder qualifizierte und das ist nicht
das Personen Klientel des zukünftig
unsere Volkswirtschaft und unsere
Betriebe rettet und deswegen ist das das
völlig falsches Signal dass sie hier
aussehen und Herr Kollege auch was der
tome gesagt hat man möge jetzt legale
Wege schaffen damit man nicht mehr
illegal nach Deutschland kommen müsste
glauben Sie denn wirklich dass wenn sie
wie mit diesem Gesetz
zusätzliche dann zukünftig legale Wege
schaffen dass dann die anderen irgendwo
auf der Welt sagen oh die Ampel hat
jetzt hier legale Wege geschafft ich
Fall da aber nicht runter dann bleibe
ich mal zu Hause sitzen die kommen
zusätzlich sie schaffen weitere Anreize
insbesondere die FDP ist hier
irreführend bei ihrem Wähler Klientel
unterwegs Herr Kollege thomesch aus
meiner Heimatstadt Heilbronn Heilbronn
kommt kam Theodor Heuss wir haben eine
lange liberale Tradition wenn ich aber
mit Menschen in meinem Wahlkreis die
auch der FDP zuneigen spreche über
dieses Gesetz und sie aufkläre was da
wirklich drinsteht dann haben sie kein
Verständnis sie machen das Projekt 5
Prozent aber von oben nach unten sie
arbeiten an ihren Wählerinnen und
Wählern vorbei und letzte Bemerkung
rückführungsoffensive
das ist eine Fass weil in dieses Gesetz
umgesetzt wird dann bleiben zum Schluss
nur noch Straftäter übrig die
abgeschoben werden müssen alle anderen
gewähren sie dauerhafte bleiberechte
herzlichen Dank
Kritik von Alexander droben hier aus der
CDU CSU-Fraktion
da liegen die Positionen sehr weit
auseinander
jetzt hören wir als fraktionslosen
Abgeordneten Robert fahle
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren das
Chancen und Aufenthaltsrecht ist nichts
anderes als die schrittweise
Legalisierung
illegaler Migration
anstatt die geltende Rechtslage nach
abgelehntem Asylantrag mit Abschiebungen
auch durchzusetzen kommt ein Gesetz das
über die Zeitschiene den gültigen
Rechtsrahmen endgültig aushebelt ein
beispielloser Fall dass der Bundestag
mit einer neuen Gesetzgebung bestehendes
Recht aushebelt selbst aushebel das ist
so das ist so als ob man
jemand Zug sitzt und wenn der Schaffner
kommt heißt es der Schwarzfahrer ist
schon so lange im Zug gefahren dass er
sich das Recht auf eine legale
Weiterfahrt erworben hat die Kette
lautet auf die
illegale Einreise folgt ein abgelehnter
Asylbescheid dann folgt die Duldung mit
Arbeitserlaubnis dann der Einstieg in
Hartz IV dann ein Bleiberecht und
schließlich kommt die Einbürgerung und
das Wahlrecht eine Kurzbeschreibung von
Deutschland im Jahr 22 lautet wer Geld
hat der wandert aus wer kein Geld hat
der wandert ein und zwar in unserer
Sozialsystem warum kommen die
hochqualifizierten Fachkräfte nicht zu
uns zu der Sprachbarriere kommen die
niedrigen Verdienstmöglichkeiten die
vergleichsweise niedrigen Bruttolöhne
treffen auf die höchsten Steuer- und
Sozialabgaben in der Welt kommen Sie
bitte zum Schluss auch noch die Idee
industrialisierungspolitik der Ampel
meine Damen und Herren lehnen Sie diesen
Gesetzentwurf ab weil er Deutschland
endgültig vor die Wand feiert vielen
Dank
machen sie es nicht
im Deutschen Bundestag gibt es derzeit
fünf fraktionslose Abgeordnete 4 von
ihnen gehörten ehemals zur afd-fraktion
wie beispielsweise Robert farle hey
gelind jetzt für die SPD der zuständige
Berichterstatter für die SPD-Fraktion zu
diesem Gesetzentwurf Ministerin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen
welchen Sinn macht es eine sechsstellige
Zahl von Personen rechtschaffen gut
integriert
jahrelang manchmal sogar jahrzehntelang
seit Geburt in einem Zustand der
Unsicherheit zu lassen teilweise
abhängig von sozialsicherungsleistungen
mit Arbeitgebern wenn Sie den Arbeiten
können die in demselben
unsicherheitszustand sind ohne
sicherheitspolitischen Mehrwert ohne
Mehrwert für die identitätsklärung und
ohne realistische Perspektive der
Rückkehr welchen Sinn macht das ich
glaube es macht keinen Sinn welchen Sinn
macht die Fortschreibung einer Blockade
und eines Selbstbetrugs keinen Sinn und
deshalb ist dieser Moment durchaus ein
historischer und deshalb bin ich
ausgesprochen dankbar für den
Gesetzentwurf der Ministerin und wir
werden als Koalition diesen
Gesetzentwurf durchbringen und damit
endlich ein Gesetz des gesunden
Menschenverstandes hier durchsetzen denn
darum geht es hier
die Menschen um die es geht
wir haben nicht als agend eine große
migrationspolitische Fragen oder open
borders oder sonst wie ihre Agenda ist
ihr eigenes Leben sie wollen einfach ihr
vernünftig leben können denn sie sind
Mitglied dieser Gesellschaft aber bisher
dürfen Sie jetzt nicht sein und das ist
der Skandal an dem wir arbeiten und den
wir ändern werden
wir zeigen mit diesem Chancen Aufenthalt
der eine Brücke ist in einer
verbessertes Bleiberecht das eben
Pragmatismus oft auch der bessere
Idealismus ist und gleichzeitig zeigen
wir dass ihre pulfaktor Ideologie
absoluter Blödsinn ist pull Faktor macht
nur in der Hinsicht Sinn dass ihr
dauerhaftes Gerede ich spreche auch von
der CDU und allen anderen die das tun
der pulfaktor ist für Wählerstimmen der
AFD das ist der einzige funktionierende
pulfaktor in diesen Zusammenhang wir
aber tun etwas was sowohl
volkswirtschaftlich als auch
migrationspolitisch als auch
integrationspolitisch als auch humanitär
und hören Sie genau zu
sicherheitspolitisch sinnvoll ist und
Fortschritte bringt und fundamentale
Fortschritte bringt und dann
kommen wir ich bin ja immer allergisch
was doppeltsüchtigkeiten und wie
Batterien betrifft kommen wir doch zur
CDU sie sprachen ja wiederholt Herr Seif
Herr Trum vom Ampel Amnestiegesetz ich
würde es eher das CDU amnesiegesetz
nennen warum
ihr eigener Ministerpräsident des
bevölkerungsreichsten Bundeslandes in
dem die meisten geduldeten Leben
zugleich auch Landesvorsitzender der CDU
des größten Landesverbandes der CDU
fordert explizit im Koalitionsvertrag
der von ihm geführten Regierung ich
zitiere alle humanitären und
aufenthaltssichernden
Bleiberechtsregelung so auszuschöpfen
dass gut integrierte geflüchtete
geduldete bleiben können und erfordert
uns explizit auf
explizit auf
zügig entsprechende gesetzliche Regelung
zu vollziehen und hat eine
vortriebsregelung getroffen ihr eigener
Ministerpräsident tut das und deshalb
stelle ich abschließend die Frage
entweder ist das was sie hier vorführen
ein riesiges Schauspiel oder wenn sie es
so ernst meinen haben sie einen
fundamentalen Lizenz einen Bruch in der
Migrationspolitik innerhalb der CDU
klären Sie das bitte und belästigen Sie
nicht uns damit herzlichen Dank
war das für die SPD-Fraktion ja es wird
dieser Gesetzentwurf hier von Nancy
fazer dann doch eben in den Ausschüssen
intensiv diskutiert werden dann geht
dann nach dieser Debatte ins
parlamentarische Verfahren